لقد صدمت حرب روسيا الشرسة في أوكرانيا
العالم ،
لكن لا ينبغي أن يفاجأ أحد
لسنوات قسوة روسيا التي لا
ترحم حتى يراها الجميع في سوريا
حيث دفع عدد لا يحصى من المدنيين ثمن
دعم بوتين لحليفه بشار
الأسد.
أكثر من 300 نوع من
الأسلحة هي أيضًا حيث اختبرت حدود
العالم ويبدو أنه لم يكن هناك
أي حرب ، ليس لها قواعد ولا أحد ينجو
منها ولا مكان آمن
للمستشفيات والمدارس في روسيا التي قصفت في روسيا والتي
وصفتها الولايات المتحدة بأنها جرائم حرب
ولكن لا أحد لديه  واجهت العدالة ،
وتنفي روسيا أنها ارتكبت هذه الجرائم ،
لكنها هجمات قاسية لا تعرف حدودًا ،
حتى أولئك الذين يهرعون لإنقاذ الجرحى
قد استُهدفوا
بضربات النقر المزدوج الشائنة ، فقد فقدت اثنين أو اثنين من
زملائي في ثانية واحدة
كنا نحاول الرد عليها  لإنقاذ الآخرين
ابتسم عبدالله من الخوذ البيضاء
نجا من واحدة من أكثر حملات روسيا وحشية
في سوريا حيث ساعدت
نظام الأسد في الحصار.  rve وقصف
حلب الشرقية للخضوع ،
اضطررنا لمغادرة
المدينة ، تحولت حلب المحبوبة إلى أنقاض
صالحة للأكل
مثل
يوم القيامة ،
رأيت
المباني المنهارة على
رؤوس عائلاتهم على رؤوس
أفراد عائلات أطفال العائلة
باستخدام  القنابل الخارقة للتحصينات التي
يستخدمها هذا النوع من الأسلحة في الطابق
السفلي العسكري الذي تم استخدامه
ضد المدنيين لاستهداف
ملاجئ المدنيين
في الجزء الصغير المتبقي من سوريا التي يسيطر عليها المتمردون
والخوذ البيضاء هي تنبيه
بوجود وقف هش لإطلاق النار هنا.
يريدون أيضًا مساعدة أوكرانيا ، فهم يعرفون
جيدًا قواعد اللعبة في روسيا ، فهم
سيقصفون كل شيء ، وقد
يقولوا ووسائل إعلامهم
أننا استهدفنا مكانًا للجنود الذين
استهدفناهم الجيوش الأوكرانية ، لذا يشعر الكثيرون هنا
بالألم الذي يعانيه الأوكرانيون
من الألم الذي تسببوا فيه.  نفس
المعتدي الذي حطم أرواح الكثير من السوريين
هذه ابنتي لمار
مدرس اللغة الإنجليزية عبد الكفيل حمدو مع
طفله ج.  ناشد irl من جانبه
العالم مرارًا وتكرارًا لإنقاذ
حلب في عام 2016
لكن العالم بدا في الاتجاه الآخر ،
فأنا لا أعرف لماذا لا يتعلم العالم ،
أعني عدم إيقاف روسيا في سوريا ، وهذا
يؤثر على أوكرانيا المتضررة أعني  إن عدم
إيقاف
بوتين في أوكرانيا سيفعل الشيء نفسه
في العديد من البلدان الأخرى
، لقد مرت أكثر من خمس سنوات منذ أن
أجبر الحامدو على ترك منزله
ليس كما يقول
ولكن الحياة
تستمر الآن يقول إنه لا يستطيع التوقف
بالتفكير في أوكرانيا ، لا أحد يستطيع أن يفهم
الأوكرانيين ، ولا أحد من العالم ، لكن
لا أحد منهم يستطيع فهمهم أكثر من
السوريين ، سوف نفهم أننا
نفهمهم أكثر ، وهذا هو السبب في أنني لا
أستطيع في الوقت الحاضر أن أقوم بالتدريس جيدًا ، ولا يمكنني فعل
أي شيء لأنني أتابع
ما يجري فقط
في الواقع ، ما يؤثر علي كثيرًا هو أن
العالم كله يكرر نفس
الخطأ ، خطأ ترك بوتين
يفلت من العقاب ، كل الإفلات من العقاب في سوريا الذي
ربما شجعه على غزو
أوكرانيا.  لا
يشعر الكثيرون هنا أن مصيرهم مرتبط الآن
بأوكرانيا إذا لم يتم إيقاف بوتين ، فهم
يخشون أن تطلق روسيا العنان للجحيم هنا مرة
أخرى لمساعدة الأسد في استعادة ما تبقى من
هذه الأرض المدمرة
germanic
cnn اسطنبول